losses that will resonate you know i
always say throw out week one
because you got 15 games left and
everything changes teams get better
teams get worse but but which of these
losses from yesterday leave a mark uh
well it's hard for me not to look at the
miami dolphins one really i mean because
there's losses and then there's
absolutely getting bludgeoned and
dominated to a point where you go
oh wow okay yeah i mean uh what was that
final score 59 to 10 59 to 10 you go oh
wow okay we lost the t-10 and ten but
they're going to go watch the film and
go we could have lost 72 to 10. we could
have lost 79 to 10. i mean that's how
bad that game was to me that's where
that was so bad so dominating so easy
for the ravens that i think it'll be a
number of weeks before the dolphins even
have any sense you know semblance of
self-confidence yeah i agree with you
completely and part of the aftermath of
that game you got guys on the team who
think that they're tanking and have told
their agents get us out of here so what
was the second one then who's that if
you went after that what's the next one
well i think losing at home
is always a bad way to start the season
for the browns i mean we've talked about
that that's a given that's going to
resonate how will freddie kitchens and
the browns handle that adversity i i
think that for the teams that had games
one that blew them right when it's a big
deal to get that win especially the
first one and in your division at home
against the division rival you're the
jets you're up 16 nothing and you blow
that one that that one's going to hurt
that's true you're going to hurt them
too even though it was a tie i still
think it hurts up 24 6 right an
embarrassment there that you know as the
game went on
the cardinals made adjustments to the
lions that the lions couldn't match yeah
i know you're exactly right i mean
that's one yes where you talk about two
different teams that arizona's gonna be
happy with the tide detroit's gonna be i
can't believe we let them come back and
have a thai football game i'll tell you
another loss that i think just looks at
it would scare me a little
is the atlanta falcons the way they lost
the way they looked in the preseason
especially up front on the offensive
line i would be a little worried there
altogether uh and then you know matt
ryan
i know he'll play well it wasn't a great
day yesterday but i mean they really
kind of got dominated in all three
phases of the football game i mean kirk
cousins didn't have to throw the
football because they ran the ball well
their defense created turnovers and they
got a block punt early in the game that
gave him a short field and that was all
she broke and they turn it around next
sunday night against the philadelphia
eagles which will not be an easy no it
won't fall into an o and two hole and
you know if the saints come out strong
again the only good news for the falcons
the buccaneers lost the panthers lost
the saints could win tonight and be the
only unbeaten team in the division but
but at least the other two teams that
played also lost that's it if you're
looking for good news for the falcons
that's the extent
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports